well it's about damn time so the trailer
for The Dark Tower finally hit and I
feel a little bit obligated to talk
about this one because they did a video
I know a month month and a half back or
so basically asking um what's going on
with this movie well we've got a trailer
finally and then you know they didn't
just drop on a nowhere they kind of
teased it they finally gave an official
poster they gave us you know these
little clips and now we've got the
proper trailer now couple reminders I
have not read the books so I don't have
that grounding or any set of
expectations based on that I know a
little bit about them in terms of the
broad ideas and sort of some of the the
ideas behind it and like most Stephen
King things I hear the idea and go huh
nifty and that could make a really good
thing or it could make something this is
near that's not necessarily on Stephen
King you know good movies bad movies
depends on the production all these
other things but I don't have a
particular inherent investment in this
is what I'm saying but at least as far
as the source material goes but I love
still really curious about the movies
because I mean these these things have
been in the works
you know some version of the dark hour
is a movie it's been in the works for
ever
um now uh I guess the thing worth noting
for folks who are fans of the books is
this is not really an adaptation this is
a sequel more or less to the book series
now it almost feels like a spoiler to
say that because I like is that even
though I haven't read them I know it I'm
not about what goes on and them that a
kind of koozie into what happens at the
end of that book that that this is
following up on that and yet it kind of
repeated anyway so how is this trailer
what are my thoughts on the actual
trailer it's okay
it's getting them X I think it's it's
okay it's not bad they're there I don't
there aren't a ton of red flags in this
but it's kind of generic and I don't
necessarily think that's a reflection of
the movie I think that
more to do with the fact that these are
the big epic sweeping stories there it's
hard to get a trailer that feels unique
with these kinds of stories in much the
same way I have talked to a previous
video that a horror movies are really
hard to cut trailers for because what
gives it its unique flavor is all in the
details in the context and the
atmosphere and sort of dwelling in that
world and you know indicator for horn
will be getting a sense of terror in the
case of something more epic like this
getting a sense of a lived in worldly
getting a sense of the epicness in the
scope of the journey and you get that by
sort of existing in that space for a
while when you're cutting a trailer
that's only a couple minutes you don't
have the time to build then so you just
sort of you do a highlights reel and it
comes across as generic so well I think
that might reflect poorly on the trailer
I don't think it necessarily reflects
poorly on the film although it does it
can still be a concern because if the
trailer reads generic fewer people are
going to go see it which means that it
you know even if it is good it might not
get the audience it deserves but um I
think the only moment that made me kinda
go hmm was the whole thing with wrong
like tossing the you know the little
thing above soft and like catching and I
mean it's kind of cool but it was very
oh people are gonna get pissed at me for
using his name like it's a curse word
again but it's very vexed nighter
the whole slow-motion doing that and
they had something similar slightly
earlier in the trailer that worked much
better for me where we just sort of you
know flicking the bullet into the
chamber like that worked I was cool with
that but then they took it like that one
step too far I'm like that's very very
matrix it's very it's not what I would
expect out of out of this property and
and you know there are other aspects to
it the whole sort of crossing universes
thing it's unfortunately that is the
story of the books as I understand them
and that's that's a tough thing because
unfortunately a lot of low-budget movies
you know since the 80s have used the
let's cross over these two worlds and
and you know have
bring them over to the real world story
gimmick as an excuse to cover a budget
because it's much easier to shoot
something in the quote unquote
real world than it is to create a
fantastical one it's why the 80s Masters
of the Universe film is set largely on
earth it's just cheaper and that I don't
think that's the reason it's happening
in the dark hour but unfortunately
movies that have done that things for
that reason for so long kind of it puts
a bit of a taint on that as a
storytelling device in movies
specifically because the reason it done
in movies is because of low budget
obviously doing it in the book it's not
doing it because it's low but is doing
because it's the story Stephen King
wanted to tell but carrying that over to
the medium of film and suddenly that as
a concept carries baggage that that it
wouldn't on the page but um it is nice
that we finally got a trailer mat early
phase August now was July I think last
time I talked about it so they did push
it back slightly um I'll be curious to
see how much more of a push they do on
this because there's part of me that
that thinks that the studio is afraid of
this movie and I'm not entirely sure why
there are a number of reasons why there
could be it could be pessimistic view
that it just stinks it could be that it
is a movie that they just don't know how
to market I mean if there if it was
really captured books which are
notoriously very you know literate and
integrated in and all these sorts of
things that are hard to translate the
film they could end up with a movie
that's true to the books but they just
don't know how to sell it or it could
just be a matter of somebody realize how
much they spend on this and they really
there's no way they're going to recoup
this money back and that's kind of what
I'm leaning towards because especially
if they factor in all the false starts
this project has in terms of you know
how much is it cost us to bring this
thing to the screen finally they may
have realized this thing might you know
do a couple hundred million domestic but
it needs to do way bigger than that to
be worth all the money in time we can
get to the
we're going to make that money back and
if that's that's the point that they've
hit they might be holding back how much
marketing they're going to put behind it
because that's just throwing more money
in the hole again this is all
speculation on my part but I guess it's
just a vibe that I get I feel like the
studio's afraid of this movie um
and ultimately when it comes out in
August we will find out if that was the
case and we'll find out if it was why
but in any case the trailer for The Dark
Tower have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give us into the
council of geeks podcast already punch
like a girl podcast both available on
iTunes and stitcher on separate podcast
feeds and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Applause]